in the first video of this series I
introduced you to the things that I
found at Ken hams Ark Encounter the
impressive structure loads of paintings
and sculptures and Hammond ISM a new
version of Christianity put together by
Ken Ham that mixes dinosaurs and a type
of hyper evolution with stories from the
Bible as a science educator I found that
several of ken ham's exhibits about
science were factually misleading one in
particular was his presentation on a
genus of animals known from the fossil
record called Archaeopteryx back in 2016
I had the privilege of visiting England
where I got to see for myself the London
specimen one of 12
Archaeopteryx skeletons that were found
in the limestone fossil beds of Germany
and now reside in different museums and
collections around the world today dear
viewer I will introduce you to
Archaeopteryx and in the following
episode we'll compare what's actually
been discovered about Archaeopteryx to
the claims being made by Ken Ham at the
Ark Encounter so cozy on up and get
ready you're about to meet Archaeopteryx
part bird part dinosaur the fossils that
helped forever change our view of the
history of life on planet Earth
[Music]
[Music]
hello John Perry here welcome to episode
2 on Archaeopteryx Archaeopteryx is a
genus a group of closely related species
that lived in the Jurassic period and
they lived in what is now Germany they
are often described as reptile like
birds or sometimes described as
bird-like reptiles because they are a
transitional genus they show a mixture
of reptilian traits and bird-like traits
the very first skeleton of Archaeopteryx
was first discovered by the scientific
community in 1861 so this was just 2
years after Darwin had published his
book On the Origin of Species scientists
were kind of unsure of it at the start
they were debating it still it was all
very fresh and then Archaeopteryx was
discovered and this fossil absolutely
amazed the scientific community for
several different reasons first of all
it was extremely extremely well
preserved this here is the London
specimen I actually took this picture
myself which is why it's not very high
quality took it on my cell phone this is
the first skeleton of Archaeopteryx that
was ever discovered we call it the
London specimen because it is now housed
at the London Natural History Museum as
you can see in this specimen not only is
the skeleton extremely well-preserved
but you can actually even see imprints
of the feathers and if we look at the
Berlin specimen and other specimens you
can see that they're even better
preserved than the London specimen this
is extremely unusual for fossils as old
as Archaeopteryx fossils from the
Jurassic period normally when something
fossilizes only like part of its teeth
will fossilize or a bit of its skull but
Archaeopteryx and a number of other
specimens we have entire skeletons for
and the special fossil beds that we find
them in are what we call lager Staton
lagers Staton is actually a German word
I don't speak German so I'm actually
pronouncing it wrong if you want to say
it right you say it like this now gosh
Tintin and lagers thought in our special
fossil beds that preserved animals so
well that you can actually usually even
see not only their entire skeletons but
also bits and pieces of what their soft
tissue may have looked like so in the
case
archeopteryx we can see these beautiful
feathers that it had on its body logger
Staton form in several different ways
one of the most common ways is through a
local catastrophe maybe like a crazy
dust storm or a mudslide or a volcano
one of my favorite examples of a
catastrophic lager Staton is the ash
fall Fossil Beds in Nebraska sadly I
have not been there it's on my wish list
what happened here is a volcano erupted
and it killed all of the animals in the
local region by suffocating them in ash
horrible way to go and because they all
died together there were no scavengers
to start eating the bodies and
scattering the bones which is what
normally happens when something dies and
because the ash continued to fall after
these animals died they were buried you
know normally if a skull were to just
sit on the ground in the Sun it's gonna
slowly oxidize when it gets wet in the
rain bacteria can grow inside of it and
start to digest even the bone the vast
majority of animals that die never
become fossils but in these rare local
catastrophes everything was preserved
another way that loggers taught inform
is when the environment somehow produces
a natural trap one of the really neat
examples of this that I actually have
been able to see for myself are the Tar
Pits in Los Angeles the La Brea Tar Pits
these are natural Tar Springs there's
tar just bubbling up out of the ground
back in the day when large animals
roamed in the area that is now known as
Los Angeles things like mammoths they
would stumble into these Tar Pits and
they would get stuck and they'd start to
freak out because they're stuck in a tar
pit and then freaking out would attract
all kinds of predators giant dire wolves
would try and get the mammoth that was
stuck in the tar saber-toothed cats
would come and try and eat the mammoths
that were stuck in this tar it was like
these predators could not resist and all
of them would die in the tar together
it's just it's this horrible trap a
horrible joke that nature played on
these animals at the time and just as a
quick little side note if you look at
any ecosystem you will find that prey
animals animals that get eaten by
predators
they always outnumber predators within a
specific environment
and the reason for that is that
predators have to eat multiple prey
animals during their life and so there
has to be more prey than there are
predators if the predator population
gets too big certain predators start to
starve to death and so the population
just naturally shrinks down again but in
the Tar Pits because these mammoths
would get stuck they would attract
predators from all around so we actually
have in this one fossil that we have
more predators than we have prey animals
they're just tons of direwolves and tons
of saber-toothed cats this is a picture
of my cousin Paige standing in front of
a giant wall of dire wolf skulls there's
just so many many dire wolf skulls that
the museum didn't even know what to do
with them they just made a big giant
wall of them hi Paige I miss ya
during the Jurassic period and what we
now call Germany natural traps formed
and were trapping all sorts of animals
it wasn't tar pits that were doing this
instead it was extremely salty lagoons
seawater that's been cut off from the
ocean or at least partially cut off when
you get a lagoon that's fully cut off
from the ocean it'll start to evaporate
and a lot of times the salinity the salt
content will rise because there was a
bunch of seawater the water is
evaporating out but that salt and the
calcium and other minerals stays in
there and it formed this nasty toxic
brine animals that would fall in there
maybe during a storm sea animals get
washed into the lagoon and it was just
so salty they would die
pterosaurs would fall into the lagoon
maybe they're going down for a little
drink and start choking on the nasty
salty water and end up falling in and
dying and little bird like reptiles
Archaeopteryx we're also falling in and
dying and because the water was so salty
it would actually pickle their little
bodies they would be preserved in brine
so here you have this giant natural trap
that's just making pickled pterodactyls
and there's nothing that could enjoy
eating these pickled pterodactyls
because everything that goes in there
all the scavengers like crabs and
whatnot that would go in there they
would die too and they could not tear
apart those bodies and scatter the bones
furthermore there's a lot of calcium and
sea water especially in warm shallow
seas there's a lot of cow
see em dissolved into the water and when
the water evaporates that calcium forms
little crystals little microscopic
crystals because the water as it starts
to evaporate it can no longer handle all
the calcium that used to be suspended in
it so that calcium falls out of
suspension it starts to crystallize with
carbon these microscopic calcium
crystals would form and they would just
fall down kind of like snow and the
water and bury those pickled animals at
the bottom of the lagoon and so we got
this beautiful fossil preservation of
all of these animals in there with
extremely fine grains falling on top of
them and allowing us to even see the
outlines in the case of Archaeopteryx
the outlines of his feathers logger
Staton remember that word there's
there's hundreds of logger Staton
throughout the world dotted across the
globe and they teach us a lot about life
on Earth much more so than the normal
bits and pieces of fossils that we
normally find so that was the first
interesting thing about Archaeopteryx
the first thing it just blew everybody's
minds the absolutely beautiful pristine
preservation of these incredible fossils
a second Archaeopteryx is a perfect
transitional fossil Archaeopteryx had
feathers and because of that in the
1800s when Richard Owen first classified
this animal he classified it as a bird
but Archaeopteryx was unlike any other
bird that anyone had ever seen before it
had teeth reptilian teeth you can see
that in the skull it had three fingers
and three claws on its wings and it had
this long bony tail now if you're not
very familiar with the anatomy of birds
you might think what's the big deal lots
of birds have long tails like macaws for
example have these huge long tails
what's the big deal about Archaeopteryx
having a long tail well a macaw does
have a long tail but that long tail is
made out of feathers the tails of all
modern birds are extremely short and
they have on the ends little nubby bone
that the tail feathers grow off of
Archaeopteryx was very different from
this it had a long bony tail and
feathers would come off of each vertebra
on that tail each tail bone
Archaeopteryx was discovered and
described right
as the theory of evolution was being
discussed by scientists the scientific
community was debating the theory of
evolution and because of this
Archaeopteryx was very controversial
people at the time thought that
Archaeopteryx was some sort of a
dinosaur or lizard that someone had
attached feathers to so they thought
that it was an actual reptile fossil and
then someone added mud to it and pressed
feathers into that mud they thought that
this was done as a trick to convince
people that evolution was was a real
thing and this was a very serious
accusation because Archaeopteryx was
described by Richard Owen it was a very
respected paleontologist at the time and
to think that he would pull this kind of
trick people were like we need to look
into this this is crazy
the other weird thing about that is that
Richard Owen was actually against the
theory of evolution he was arguing
against it at the time so to think that
he would have perpetuated this fraud
it's kind of a weird thing to think but
people were so outraged by this fossil
they thought it must be a fraud it was
too perfect it was a perfect
confirmation of Darwin's theory just two
years after the theory was published
what are the odds of that happening
right so they looked into it it was
debated and investigated intensely and
finally it was just too obvious the
fossil was in fact real not only that
but eleven more specimens were
eventually found in Germany in that same
area there is no longer any doubt
Archaeopteryx
was a real bird-like dinosaur and nobody
could do anything to deny that this
fossil really helped us understand the
origin of birds that birds indeed
evolved from reptiles and it really
helped the scientific community get
behind the idea of evolution and start
to accept it as a scientific concept the
third thing that Archaeopteryx did for
us was it confirmed beyond all
reasonable doubt that bird wings are
modified arms and hands now people who
were studying Anatomy at the time
already pretty much knew this if you
look at a bird's wing if you look at the
bones you've got one bone two bones
wrist hand and finger bones inside the
wing if you look at any bird
it's got this huge breastbone this huge
you know it's similar to our chest bone
but it's got this big keel in the middle
and there's these giant pectoral muscles
that pretty much take over the entire
bird's body I mean a bird is mostly like
pecks and feathers that's what a bird is
to most scientists it was obvious that
bird wings were modified arms already
but to people in the general public
wings don't look anything like arms
that's why so many artists will paint
mythical beasts like Pegasus and kind of
just glue wings on their backs you know
in reality this thing could not fly
angels the way that that artists
typically paint them there's absolutely
no way that those bodies would work in
order for a wing to flap it needs these
huge pectoral muscles
Archaeopteryx made it very very clear
that wings are in fact modified
reptilian arms now just to add to this
fact if you look at chicken embryos as
they develop they're just really neat
study done a few years back where they
would interrupt an egg during
development at certain stages they take
out the embryo and they diet so you
could see the bones actually it's the
cartilage because bones start out as
cartilage and you can actually see the
chicken wings forming they started out
as three fingered arms and those arms
would get more and more wing like until
finally you get this structure that
looks like a chicken wing if you look at
this as its developing the bones that
are inside this chicken wing as it's
developing they correlate exactly to the
bones that we find in the hand of
Archaeopteryx there is just absolutely
no way to deny this any longer
bird wings are modified arms today we
learned a new word logger stopped or in
the plural logger Staton logger Staton
our fossil beds that preserve animals so
well that we get their entire skeletons
and sometimes we even get the outlines
of soft tissue they can form through
local catastrophes or they can form
through natural animal traps
we learned that Archaeopteryx was an
extremely important fossil because it
really helped confirm the theory of
evolution back in the 1800s when the
scientific community was debating it
I mean people still do debate evolution
today but it's not the actual scientific
community that's
we have long since achieved what's
called scientific consensus about
evolution and finally Archaeopteryx
confirmed once and for all that bird
wings are in fact modified reptilian
arms if you enjoyed this video but you
have not yet subscribed to my channel
make sure to do that right now by
clicking the subscribe button and the
little Bell next to it clicking on that
bell make sure that you get a
notification when I published the next
video in this series in the next video I
will look at what Ken Ham has to say
about Archaeopteryx we're going to
compare his display to what we actually
know from the fossil record so that'll
be a fun video make sure to stay tuned
and check that one out so long for now
stay curious